What was the purpose of starting
a show called The New Negroes?
Well, it was to create a space
for people to exchange ideas,
go to church
in a certain way.
I like church.
I do the rap stuff,
Baron's the stand up.
But don't try to brand us
or put us in handcuffs
for fans up,
jealousy got into music.
To you it feels new, but it's
not confusing New Negro.
Some people that stand up,
a word or a scene
they was not aware of.
We heard you believe
what the media told you.
Them old ideas get blown up,
behold the New Negro.
This, that and the third.
Man you say you seen it all,
and you sound absurd.
This is The New Negros,
are you excited?
I feel like when I tell people
I went camping
for the first time they're like
but you're a full adult.
But I'm Black.
I see what's going on.
Welcome to revolution brother.
Why y'all new Negroes,
y'all both almost 40.
The New Negroes with Baron Vaughn
and Open Mike Eagle.
Premieres April 19th at 11.